Hello, everyone. This is Anne from Conner's Clinic. Welcome to the genetic review.
So the goal of this genetic review is to go over the report to help you better understand
what all of this information means.
You most likely have already received your full report that looks very similar to this.
I will say that some of the reports may look a little different. This is the most current update version that happened just this week.
So I believe July 12th. So just a few days ago, they did a major update on the way the report looks and kind of the functions and things like that.
So your report may look a little different, but this is the report and what it looks like.
And you also should have received a summary.
So we create a summary that is highlighted with yellow highlights on the genes that are at risk or important genes for us to address.
Obviously based on your variance and what is important. So look at that as well.
So again, you'll have this full report, which is all of the genetic data that is pulled for you.
And then you'll also have your summary, which is a shortened up version.
That is a little more kind of bullet point like and the highlighted yellow genes are the ones that are important to address for you.
So within the high those highlighted areas, it may give you some suggestions as far as a dietary intervention, a supplement intervention or a lifestyle intervention.
And those are things that are all options. We're not asking you to implement all of those.
They are options to help support that specific genetic variant.
You're going to have another document that says genetic action steps. So those are the actual action steps that we would like you to implement based on all of this data.
And we're making those recommendations based on obviously your genetics, but then also what we already currently have you on.
So your current supplement nutritional protocol that you're doing.
We're looking at supplements that you might already be taking at just on your own things that you've shared with us that you're currently taking.
So we're compiling all of that information along with the genetic information and the action steps are the things that we want you to add that might be missing from your current protocol that will be beneficial to optimize your health based on genetic weaknesses.
So that is the goal of this is to really take a look at these genetic pathways and identify these weaknesses to see where we might need to provide a specific nutrient or give a little extra support really to help optimize the function of the body as a whole.
So if you have weaknesses and detox, there's specific things that we can do. Once these weaknesses, the areas are identified that can really help in overall wellness, which then just puts your body in a better position to fight cancer, fight autoimmune disease, you know, fight any mood issues or anything that you've got going on that you just haven't seem to, you know,
been able to identify kind of a root cause or something and an implementation of a lifestyle diet, a dietary recommendation that can really help.
So the goal of this is to just empower people that even though you might have a genetic weakness, there are definitely things that you can do to help support these and information as power, the more that we know about ourselves, the more we can help ourselves and we can make better decisions
to really, you know, either deal with a current health crisis or prevent one from happening in the future. So with all of that being said, I'm looking at this report.
In another video, I did go through and explain what the, you know, these everything means on this. And I apologize, I'm going to go through it again. So if this is a review for you, you know, you can tune me out for a few minutes here, but some people watching this video may not have watched that other one.
So really, when we're looking at this report, we have the genes listed over here. These are all gene families that relate to a specific thing.
So the first areas are gut health that we look at. So these are gene, a gene family that relates to gut health. This one in particular happens to be related to gluten.
So these are the individual gene variants or the gene name. The variance column gives us an indication as to where we might have these genetic weaknesses. So if there is nothing inside a particular box, that means there is no genetic variant for that gene.
One, that means you've inherited a variant from one of your parents, if there is a two, see if I can find a two here.
Okay, here's one. So if you have a two, that means you've inherited a variant from both parents. So when you have these ones in two, there is potential for the gene family to not quite work as well as it should.
So that's what we're really looking at. Where do you have these variants and what family of gene are these variants in what's the function of that gene and might we need to do some things to help support that based on those weaknesses.
The circle here with the color different colors and different numbers, the numbers can either be positive or negative.
They relate to an interaction piece that we have on our end you guys with your PDF obviously won't be able to click on any of these and see these graphs.
But if I click on that, it brings up this bell curve here. So for each gene family, there is kind of a summary for risk assessment for that gene family. So that's the circle and the color and the positive or negative number.
So the color is indicating right to left where you're falling underneath this bell curve.
So there's a blue line here. This is the line for the client as an individual or you as an individual.
And then the red line here is the average of where everybody whose DNA has been analyzed and is within this database. I think there's over 50,000, 50,000 individual samples of DNA that have been analyzed in this database. So there's a rather large database to make comparisons between where you fall.
And where the average of people are falling. So that is this line here again the blue is where you are at in the red is the average right now in this sample.
These lines are on top of each other. So just indicating that you know kind of this sample is right in line with the average.
The color here from blue to red so kind of left to right indicates risk. So the more variance you have the more your line is going to be over here on the red side for risk.
The fewer variance you have the more your line will move to the left side for less risk. So again, the color is where you're falling underneath the bell curve.
And then the number whether it's positive or negative indicates how far you're string from this average. So the more risk you have or the more variance you have the more negative your number becomes goes to negative three.
The less risk that you have the more positive your number becomes goes to a positive three for no variance in a gene family.
And in the middle it's it's zero. So it's right at the average there. So for this H LA gene, you can see that the circle is green and the number is zero. So right at the average.
And then this metrics number gives you a clue as to how common it is for somebody to have this exact same genome type that you have a single variant and the type of variant that you have. So for this single variant here 47.3% of the people again within this database also have that so you get an idea of how common it is. So that's fairly common to have that.
This variant here is that 24% so it's a little less common. So that is factored into the risk assessment the more rare yet a variant is the higher the risk kind of quotient goes up. It just indicates we might need to dig a little deeper. So that's what these circles are and they're in each category.
All right. So looking at these first sections of the report again relating to gut health.
So the HLA genes, the KIA agents all have to do with a potential for gluten sensitivity. So any gene variance that you have in these families really does indicate an increased need for you to avoid gluten within your diet.
So you might not notice any, you know, really symptoms. You might not have still a celiac disease. But again, any variants here just make it harder for your body to break down and digest that.
That gluten and we know that gluten is inflammatory can inflame the gut.
This is really, you know, kind of a major foundational component to ill health is any time there's leaky gut or gut health issues. It can lead to a whole host of problems. So avoiding gluten if you have variants here.
Dairy. So this is a gene that looks at the lactose component in dairy. So this is the sugar component. It's not looking at the protein, the case in in dairy. It's just looking at how your body creates the enzyme to break down the lactose component of dairy.
And this is the gene that is a little bit confusing for people because actually when you have variants here, it keeps the gene turned on so you're more likely to be able to digest lactose.
If you don't have any variants that is equal to the normal expression of the gene and the normal expression of this gene is for it to turn off as we age. So as we age, we lose the ability to break down the lactose.
You know, you know, you know, you can't be a person who all through childhood adolescence, you know, young adulthood, you were able to digest dairy or consume dairy with no problems. And now as you've gotten older, you found that you have a reaction, you know, maybe it's causing gas or bloating or maybe you get some diarrhea after you eat some ice cream.
And if you have no variants here, the normal expression would be to not be able to digest lactose as well as we age. So variants here, increase your likelihood that you're still able to tolerate lactose. However, when we're dealing with our cancer patients, we know that dairy can encourage growth.
And it can be a cancer driver. So we may have asked you to stay away from dairy because it's a cancer driver for you.
We may have advised you to stay away from dairy just because we know it can be inflammatory and it can encourage growth. So we typically are wanting to limit or avoid dairy with our cancer patients.
Mold peanuts and caffeine metabolism. So this peanut allergy category really is is are the same genes that are related to mold sensitivity.
So when you have variants here, you're more likely sensitive to mold peanuts can be high and mold. So the recommendation here if you have variants would be well avoid peanuts because they again tend to be high and mold.
And then if you think that you might be living in an environment where there might be some mold or working in an environment where there might be mold spending any significant amount of time in mold exposure is really detrimental.
So you're going to want to get that, you know, remediated if that is the case, you can do some testing.
But we refer people to a third party. It's called immunolytics. And certainly if you need more information on that on that, it should be outlined in your summary, the website to go for more information.
But that's where you can order testing kits to test to see if you have mold in certain rooms in your home.
And if you do, then you certainly want to work to get that taken care of because that is also a major contributor to ill health is mold.
And as far as you know peanuts, you know, switching to an almond butter or something else where you're not getting the peanut butter that would that would be beneficial.
These genes here are related to altered responses to caffeine. So if you have variants here, you might be become more stimulated from caffeine.
And so just wanting to make sure that you're not overstimulating your body, you know, putting stress on the adrenal glands. If you have issues with sleep or anxiety and you have variants here in these caffeine genes, you might want a limiter avoid caffeine.
This CYP-1A2 gene is also kind of related to detoxing of caffeine and mold. So the CYP category of genes has to do is also involved in phase one of detox. So this gene family is helping your body get rid of toxic mold exposure.
Alright, vitamin A. So this gene here, the BCMO-1 gene helps us to convert beta carotene into the active form of vitamin A, which is what your cells need in order to remain healthy.
So this is in the gut health section because the cells that line the digestive tract really rely on vitamin A in order to maintain health.
And just, you know, as we mentioned before, we know that gut health is foundational to overall health. So if you have variants here and you're not getting adequate amounts of vitamin A, you might have a lot of gut health issues.
You might be thinking, well, I take probiotics. I eat the right foods. I don't understand why I still have gut health issues. Well, it could be because of variants in this BCMO-1.
You don't have adequate amounts of the active form of, excuse me, excuse me, the active form of vitamin A.
And with this gene, you can be eating vegetables, you know, red and orange vegetables that are high on beta carotene, but your body doesn't convert the beta carotene into vitamin A.
So going to the store and buying a vitamin A supplement that is beta carotene is not really going to help you. You need the correct form of vitamin A in order to support variants in this category.
ABP-1. So this is a gene that is related to histamines and the breakdown of histamines within the gut. And so this can be a major issue contributor to inflammation in the gut.
When histamine combines with gluten within the gut, it can create something called zonulin.
Zonulin is what opens up those tight junctions between the cells that line the digestive tract, and it creates that pathway for leaky gut.
So we want to address histamines within the gut if you have variants here. This NSAID sensitivity gene is actually this one here.
This third one down, if you have variants here, it's going to be important for you to be careful when you're taking the over the counter pain medications, you know, ibuprofen.
Your body does not process NSAIDs as well as it should. And so it could be toxic to you. So you might want to freshen up on some natural ways to help manage pain versus NSAIDs.
And we're looking at histamine metabolism here, this HNM T gene is related to histamine metabolism within tissue.
So again, variants here just hinder the body's ability to break down histamine.
So histamine is part of a normal immune response. Anytime there's an antigen or a potential threat within the body, histamine is released by the mast cells near that area where that potential threat is, and that histamine is a signal to the immune system that it needs to come in and figure out and take care of whatever this antigen is.
So normal good response to have that histamine released, but your body is supposed to break down histamine very quickly after that is released.
And if your body does not do that adequately, then you're sending those inflammatory signals when they shouldn't be there and that is not good.
So we want to address histamine within the tissue as well. We might choose histamine scavenger or natural clear hiss, something like that to help address histamine.
And if you have issues with this, you might have symptoms of, you know, you could have itchy skin, you could have rashes, you know, eczema, you could have heart palpitations, sinus congestion headaches migraines, you know, you might kind of feel hyper anxious.
So those are all kind of related to high histamine. So really we relate this to symptoms, you know, seasonal allergies, things like that. So we relate to symptoms and we'll address this, maybe put you on a low histamine diet, provide extra support with supplementation.
M-A-O-A and M-A-O-B are also involved in processing histamine, riboflavin is a component that's B2. So riboflavin is necessary as a necessary coal factor for histamine degradation.
So we will look at those and these genes as well are all related to helping break down histamine.
These are histamine receptors. So again, issues on histamine receptors can hinder the ability to have an adequate histamine response and break down. So those are all important genes there.
This next category is looking at oxalates. So oxalates are found in some of the foods that we consider to be very healthy foods that people might be consuming.
Spinach, kale, beets are listed there. So these are plant foods that are high in oxalates. Oxalates are protective measure for the plants. So when we are consuming these plants, we are getting those oxalates and your body is really supposed to just pass those were not supposed to absorb oxalates.
So if we have a scenario where we have leaky gut, oxalates are passing through that barrier entering the bloodstream, oxalates can combine with calcium to create crystals or stones. So variance here can lead to stone formation, kidney stones, gold stones, things like that.
So any variance here can be related to stone formation or high oxalates. We have something called oxalate balancer or oxalate scavenger that can help if this is an issue for you.
FUT2 is a gene family that really helps to create that mucus layer that lines the digestive tract.
And that is important because all of the beneficial bacteria that we really want in our gut they reside and live off of that mucus layer.
You can be taking all of these wonderful probiotics, but if you don't have that healthy mucus layer, the probiotics are not going to thrive in the gut environment. So we need to support that that mucus layer, we do that.
But we can do that with sun spectrum, we can do that with prebiotic fiber food such as bananas that are a little more green, artichokes, asparagus, leeks. So those are all ways to get prebiotic fiber, you know, from a dietary source or, of course, we do have some supplementation for that sun spectrum has prebiotic fiber.
Along with probiotics, so that is great for gut health support.
We have clear SBI pro as well. So we have some options for gut health, many options for gut health and that mucus layer.
Fats, carbs and proteins. So these are all genes that are involved in breaking down the fats, carbs and proteins that obviously we're consuming from food, get them into the right components so that they can enter into the mitochondria of the cells.
And go through the Krebs cycle ultimately to produce ATP for cellular energy. Obviously cellular energy is very important because our cells need to perform specific functions in order for your body to work.
So if we, if we're not getting adequate amounts of ATP, we can feel extreme fatigue. We can have, you know, be lacking in nutrient absorption.
And so we want to address this for mitochondrial health.
So these are all genes involved in that the PEMT gene is important for the production of colon, colon is important for liver health, for brain health, really important for the cell membrane, the cell membrane is composed of a
phospholipid bilayer and phosphatidyl colon is very important for the health and integrity of that membrane.
So colon is a precursor to phosphatidyl colon and this PEMT gene creates that colon. So if we have issues here are variants here, we really need to take a look at supporting these variants so that we can have healthy, healthy cell membrane.
FADS. So this gene is important for breaking down the fats, the omega-3s that we get within our foods and getting them into the, you know, appropriate fatty acids again to get into that might, the mitochondria for energy.
So variants here indicate a weakness and need for for support and you might need to supplement with omega-3s that are fish oil derived in order to support this pathway.
We have something called fatty acid assist that, you know, gives the body all the right components to help this process as well.
These genes here, this TNF gene, so this, this gene indicates a propensity for a body to be stuck in an inflammatory state. So this is an important one to look at and, you know, work on reducing inflammation if this is the case or if you have variants here.
So we can see right here it says NA not available. So sometimes in the genetic report in the sample that's provided they aren't able to type for for a certain gene and this is the case for this particular gene in this particular sample.
Once in a while that happens it doesn't happen very often but once in a while that does happen.
All right, these genes here are involved, you know, in again, breaking down carbs and proteins for the Krebs cycle.
APOE is an important gene that is looking at, it can be an indicator of cholesterol issues. So there's different typeings.
I've heard of the APOE4 gene in relation to Alzheimer's risk. So you can look at your genotype here. So this in this sample we have TT and CC as the genotype. So you can go over here and, okay, TT, CC.
Sample has an E3, E3 genotype. That's considered normal. If you have any of the versions where you have the E4 variant, those are increased risk for Alzheimer's disease and issues with cholesterol.
E2 is lower risk and so I'm going to want to assess this in relation to cholesterol and then all cell relation in relation to trying to reduce risk of Alzheimer's disease.
All right, now I'm looking at glutathione. So GSH stands for glutathione. So looking at glutathione production and regeneration.
Glutathione is an important, it's considered a master antioxidants. So it works to neutralize free radicals. Free radicals are normally produced within the body just by our normal cellular metabolic function.
And your body does produce some free radicals. And depending on exposures, you know, if we're smoking, if we're living in an environment where the air is polluted, things like that, we are going to produce extra free radicals in addition to the ones that the body normally produces. So we can have this out of balance scenario of free radicals.
So for glutathione plays a major role is neutralizing those free radicals. So they are not destructive. It donates an electron to those free radicals so that they are stabilized.
And then glutathione also recycles itself. It's one of the only anti oxidants that recycles itself so it can continually donate that electron.
So it is important for that to also important for phase one and phase two of detoxification and your body can make this glutathione. So these are genes that are all related to the production of glutathione. So
glycine is an important component necessary to produce glutathione. So variants here we might need to address some ways to increase glycine. Beats are a great source of trimethyl glycine.
So, you know, from a dietary perspective, including beats within the diet is good.
Sistine is also an important component and an acetyl cysteine may be helpful if people have variants on a specific gene.
Glutathione utilization. So we need to be able to utilize that glutathione when it's produced and these are all genes that are related to that. So these are really, you know, related to detoxing chemical sensitivities, getting rid of, you know, whether it's heavy metal or large, you know, chemical.
So it's really important to detoxing these things. And so if we have issues here, we might be really sensitive to toxins. So if you're a person that, you know, you're walking through the mall and you pass by particular stores where you they love to just spray the cologne in the perfumes all over and you can smell that.
If you just are so sensitive to smells your body just has a reaction to that is an indication that you might need support with glutathione or, you know, glutathione precursors or glutathione recycling. So your body needs that glutathione.
Any variants here, you know, we'll look at and address if we need to support different areas of glutathione. We first want to make sure that you are being able to recycle your glutathione. If you cannot recycle it.
It might not be good to just give you glutathione because that could be, you know, not very helpful. So, so we're looking at all of those these genes here related to glutathione, SOD and catalysts are, our genes are specifically involved in neutralizing the super oxide free radical.
This is the most abundant pre radical that is produced within the body. And so we have these specific genes that work together to neutralize it. So SOD stands for super oxide dismutase. So that is the gene necessary to process the first step in neutralizing the super oxide free radical and then catalyst comes in as well.
And so we want to address those to make sure we don't have an overproduction of, you know, hydrogen peroxide hydroxyl free radical. So those can be detrimental to health. So we look at these pathways, make sure that is not an issue.
But pond one pathway is a big one that we look at. We talk a lot about pond one and with our cancer patients this pathway is what helps us to get rid of herbicides pesticides and really all large chemicals. And so we see a lot of patients who have variance in the pond one pathway that definitely need support if you have that because we know that
pesticide herbicide use is just, you know, overwhelming. There's not really any way we can get away from it. We can choose organic as much as possible, but we're still probably going to be getting some exposure to herbicides and pesticides.
This top gene here is the one that is the most important in this category.
And in this sample, we have a single variant here. So definitely want to support the pond one pathway. So we do want to choose organic fruits and vegetables.
You want to look at the dirty dozen clean 15 list and make sure that you're buying the things that are listed as the dirty dozen are the most highly sprayed.
So you want to make sure you're buying those organic to reduce your burden or your exposure as much as possible. You don't want to be spraying your yard with chemicals to kill the weeds.
You know, you're going to want to pay attention to vaccines and gradients and vaccines. This is part of the pathway that is used to detox from vaccines. If you have variance here, you, you know, might not detox those appropriately. So it is important to pay attention to these things. So we do have a supplement called pond one assist. It's also part of Dr Connors.
Supplement line relating to his seven phases of detoxification. And so you're going to want to look at that if we have pond one variance here.
All right. And then looking at NRF 2 and keep one. So these are genes that are related to glutathione and allowing glutathione to get where it needs to go within the body to really, you know, put out those inflammatory fires. So we, we are also looking at NRF 2 and keep one.
And if we have variance here, again, we might not be able to get the necessary components to the area of that inflammation or that internal fire to squelch that. So these are important to look at.
So this is really starting to look at how the body is able to produce methyl groups, methyl groups are a carbon with three hydrogens attached to them. So CH3 and these little methyl groups will attach to different sections of DNA and they turn sections off, which is a good thing because we don't need all of our DNA to be interpreted.
So our cells know how to behave. And so methylation is important for cellular differentiation. It is important for detox. It is important for DNA repair. So just hundreds and hundreds of functions are dependent upon healthy methylation starts with folate and getting adequate folate within the diet.
So we can relate genes that are related to folate receptor sites. If we have issues here, we definitely will need more folate in the diet.
CHFR is another kind of rate limiting step in the production of these methyl groups. And it's very important here that if we have variance in really the supplies to anyone, whether you have variance or not, you should not be taking the synthetic version of folate, which is folic acid.
folic acid because it's very similar to the active form folate can folic acid can bind to receptor sites on cells before it's in that active form.
And it can block those receptor sites. So that is not good. So you don't want to take folic acid, you want to get folate from your foods or in supplement form, it should say folate on the supplement list. That's how you can determine if your supplement is quality or not. You don't want folic acid.
We have the empty HFR genes here. So these top two ones are the ones that are most important. We have this C677T. So variance here are linked to high homocysteine, cardiovascular disease issues with detox.
Variants in the other version, this a1298c are more related to the bioptron pathway, which is regulating neurotransmitters. So this might be related more so to mood issues, you know, depression, anxiety,
OCT, OCD type behaviors, those things. So again, variance here indicated an increased need for folate in its natural form and B vitamins, you know, B6, B2. Those are cofactors and in all of this methyl production, methyl group production pathway. So we need B vitamins.
And we need folate. So folate from a dietary perspective is found in leafy greens and cruciferous vegetables. So make sure you're getting those in on a daily basis. You might be taking the greens first powder. That's a great source of natural folate as well.
And continuation of how the body produces these methyl groups, we need B12. So MTR and MTR are related to B12 and the ability to have enough B12 to combine with, you know, the the methylation process here, the metabolite of this methylation process to create the methyl groups.
So without adequate amounts of B12, you're not going to be, this isn't going to be happening as well as it should. So the top two, this one here, the top one in the MTR category, and then the top one in the MTR are category are the most important.
So issues are variants here, you might need supplementation with vitamin B12, which is cabalamin and there's different forms of cabalamin, you do not want cyanocabalamin that is the synthetic version.
And you don't want that there's a denisil cabalamin and pro hydroxyl cabalamin. So those are cabalamin combined with an adenisil group or a hydroxyl group. Those are adequate forms that you can take with our cancer patients, we do not want you to take methyl cabalamin, methyl groups as we previously discussed.
Can attach to the sections of DNA and they turn things off. So if we are supplementing with high amounts of methyl groups, methyl groups are the number one thing that turn off tumour suppressor genes.
So we don't want you to be taking supplements in the methylated form if you have cancer. So we use pro hydroxyl cabalamin. If you don't have cancer, then a methylated version, methyl cabalamin is fine.
But you can take adenisil cabalamin or pro hydroxyl cabalamin, if you have a diagnosis.
All right, to MAT and GMAT are also involved, kind of offshoots of the whole methylation cycle, but they are important in the process. MAT is something that converts methionine down to homocysteine. If you have variance here, you might have excess methionine cancer can feed off of methionine.
That's an amino acid and so we might have you on a low animal protein diet, a low amino acid diet, if you have variance in this methionine category.
All right, here is another pathway that is related to the methylation cycle. So this is a shortcut pathway for recycling of homocysteine to methionine.
And if you have variance here in this BHMT gene, either O8 or the O2, you could push the, push the process. So it's not recycling well and you could be pushing a process called transselpheration, which the end points there are
are are can increase anxieties, you can have excess glutamates, excess ammonia, and those things are not good when they are in excess. So we look at this pathway, provide support. So we're not pushing the transselpheration pathway, if it's necessary.
And then we see a repeat of this PEMT gene that we discussed in the gut health section, or actually I believe it was in the fats, carbs, and proteins section. So this is also important in that recycling of homocysteine to methionine.
CBS is an important pathway as well. And again, we can be pushing this. If we have issues with with the BHMT gene, we can push things through this CBS pathway, which really pushes the gas pedal to the production of glutamates and ammonia can lead to adrenal fatigue and kind of anxiety like symptoms.
Here's this CTH gene. I mentioned this earlier in relation to glutathione production and cysteine. So if you have variants here, you might need to support with some cysteine transselpheration. So this is the pathway that
that pulls homocysteine down and takes it into the ammonia, glutamates. You know, it does produce some glutathione and then it can increase cortisol. So we check this these pathways here to see if
if that is happening and we will address that we look at neurotransmitter genes and really the important thing for us here when we're looking at the neurotransmitter genes is to help us get a picture as to your autonomic nervous system. So we have two branches of the autonomic nervous system. We have the
parasympathetic branch, which is rest digested and healed. And this is where we want you to be dominant because of course this is where healing takes place.
The other branch of the autonomic autonomic nervous system is the fight or fight response, the sympathetic nervous system. And a lot of times patients are stuck in this sympathetic state where, you know, they're stressed. They've just received a diagnosis.
It's completely understandable to be in this fight or fight mode when you're dealing with a health crisis. So the key is to acknowledge that and help shift the nervous system actively work to shift the nervous system into that parasympathetic branch. So when we're looking at neurotransmitters, we have genes that are involved in the production of neurotransmitters and breakdown of neurotransmitters.
Dopamine, serotonin, epinephrine, nor epinephrine. And if we have issues here, you know, it can just lead to that whole cycle of the stress, the sympathetic dominance anxiety and insomnia. We know that all of these things need to be addressed if we want true healing. So we're looking at the balance here.
COMT is related to dopamine and how your body, you know, breaks that down. These little arrows here. So if it's a down a red down arrow, it indicates a down regulation of that gene. So when you have this sample here, this person has a double a little variance. So their COMT gene is really down regulated. That means dopamine is not being processed adequately. They might have high levels of dopamine.
Dopamine is something that helps us focus. No dopamine is a good neurotransmitter. All the neurotransmitters are good, but we're just talking about how do we maintain that balance. So we have the right
The right balance. And so to higher to low is not is not ideal. So if we have to high of dopamine, we can kind of have a hair trigger temper. We might be kind of obsessively compulsed with things. We might have roominating thoughts.
And so we want to do things to address this. We can use glutamate scavenger. We can use magnesium magnesium L3 and 8 is great for brain health and calming the nervous system. So there's a lot of things that we can do to help.
If we have COMT variance, M-A-O-A and M-A-O-B are related to serotonin production and breakdown of serotonin. And so again, issues here can lead to lack of motivation, some depression or blues or anxiety.
You startle easily. So so things like like this. So we want to create that balance serotonin is also related to production of melatonin. So if you're not producing enough serotonin, then you most likely might not be producing enough melatonin. So you might have issues with sleep
So we look at those. We're also looking at this GAD gene here, which is related to GABA. So glutamates are excitatory neurotransmitters. So if you need to gear up for a work project or, you know, you're gearing up for exercise or whatever it is.
You're giving us speech, putting on a presentation or something. We need glutamates to kind of get the body awake alert active so we can perform these tasks. But then we need the balancing neural transmitters to come in. So your body can recover from that.
And so GABA is is the calming neural transmitter. And this GAD gene is what takes the excitatory glutamates and converts them into calming GABA. So issues or variants here, we might be stuck in a more excitatory state harder to relax harder to calm down.
Again, might have ruminating thoughts, you know, might be just stuck in a pattern of, you know, oh my gosh, that you know fight you got in with your spouse or your child or that disagreement and you might, you know, it's harder takes longer for you to kind of move on from that if you have variants here.
So definitely things we can do with diet, so reducing glutamates in your diet, so reducing packaged foods, monosodium glutamate is in many packaged foods, a flavor enhancer, it's intentionally put in there maliciously
to excite the brain cells and to make you addicted or want more of that food. So you're eating a Dorito chip and high in MSG. So it's just lighting up your brain, your brain wants more, so it's addictive. And so by not eating those things that are have MSG and them in the packaged foods, you're eliminating that source.
Animal proteins can have
Elglutamine, which is an amino acid, which can convert to glutamate. So, you know, if you really struggling with some of these symptoms, you can reduce your animal protein.
Things like that, the DAO gene is also involved in kind of getting rid of glutamates and excitatory neurotransmitters. This DAOA gene, this bottom one here specifically is related to excitability in the brain variance here will increase that excitability and can be detrimental linked to conditions such as schizophrenia and bipolar
or smell having variants here or a predisposition for that these conditions does not mean that you're going to have those conditions. And this is just such, this is the value of having this genetic test is comes in to play when we see, okay, these gene variants here are linked to a specific condition, I have that. So what can I do to prevent that.
So really the things that we've talked about, you know, just previously, reducing glutamates, reducing monosodium glutamates, reducing animal protein, you know, anything that can excite those brain cells is going to be helpful.
We have a product called benzene, which is great to help reduce glutamates in the brain as well. So we're looking at all of these OXTR, this is the gene related to oxytocin.
And so if you have variants here, you can really struggle with stress, be more sensitive to stress.
So we want to address stress, we might recommend some adaptogenic herbs. If we have issues here in any of these neurotransmitter categories or genetic variants adaptogenic herbs can be really helpful to just balance. If you're running too hot, you know, it helps to bring you down if you're running too low, it helps to bring up a little bit. So adaptogenic herbs like ashwagandha can be really helpful.
All right, so let's see here the next category is BH4 support. So this is really a feeder pathway to the neurotransmitter section. And so some of these genes are genes we've, we've looked at DHFR is in the folate section.
So green is getting full late in your diet is healthy to support BH4 production for healthy neurotransmitter balance.
So we're looking at those neuroplasticity. So neuroplasticity is really how the brain adapts if there is something getting in the way of the synapses between neurons.
And so something like a concussion, so physical trauma, something an emotional trauma. So a cancer diagnosis or if there's, you know, a divorce or some emotional trauma death in the family, those things can can cause disturbances in the synapses between these neurons.
And then of course, chemicals can so a toxin can disrupt these neurotransmitters. So how able is your brain to adapt if these things are blocking pathways, can your can your brain adapt and create new pathways. So we have, you know, full, full function and a healthy brain.
So these are all genes that are related to that exercise is probably the number one thing that you can do to increase neuroplasticity and to encourage brain health, eating dark purple foods wild blueberries, purple cabbage purple potatoes, eggplants, all of these purple foods encourage brain health.
So we're looking at these and providing support if necessary, looking at NOS and circulation. So NOS is an important gene to help us produce nitric oxide, which is important for the cardiovascular system.
So we look at these genes here. If we have too high of nitric oxide, you know, there can be some imbalances that produce something called peroxinite trite, which is something that is not wanted within the body. It is, you know, an oxidizing agent can cause damage can be related to, you know, aches and pains brain fog.
You know, many different different things. So nitric oxide is involved in that. This gene is involved in that. So we're looking to see if this these pathways need support so we can prevent the production of that peroxie nitrite.
And what we can do to support that.
And we're also looking at genes here that are related to blood pressure, so hypertension and in a predisposition for that, certainly lifestyle choices, diet, gut health, dietary choices, exercise, all of those things, Trump variance that you have in the cardiovascular system. So those are all important to maintain a healthy heart healthy blood pressure.
Healthy circulation.
We are looking at vitamin A and vitamin D. So vitamin A was in the gut health section, the SpCMO1 gene.
And then the vitamin D genes are listed here. So both vitamin A and vitamin D are very important for cancer patients.
Vitamin A helps to, helps with cell differentiation. So it encourages maybe some abnormal cells to become normal.
Vitamin D can bind to receptor sites on cancer cells and stimulate a poptosis, which is death of those cancer cells. So we want to make sure we're getting adequate amounts of vitamin A and vitamin D.
If we have variants here, we most certainly need to support from a dietary perspective or possibly supplementation.
It's a little bit harder to get those fat soluble vitamins from foods, because they might be in foods that, you know, maybe we don't like, you know, like liver, vitamin A and vitamin D are in liver eggs are the yolk of eggs is high in vitamin A and vitamin D.
But sometimes people, you know, maybe advised not to eat eggs, maybe they have an egg allergy, maybe eggs or animal protein came up as your cancer driver. So you're avoiding those things. So we might need to supplement.
We use a product called ADK eval, which is all of the fat soluble vitamins. So it's vitamin A, D, K and vitamin E. Did I already say that? I can't remember.
But all of the fat soluble vitamins and there's lots of studies that show when you're getting all of them together, they work synergistically to help create the desired boost that you need. So ADK eval.
All right, let's see here looking at mTOR and atophagy. So the balance between mTOR and atophagy is kind of like a teeter totter mTOR genes are signaling for growth atophagy the genes of this category are signaling for cellular repair and cleanup.
So in today's day and age, we are pretty much constantly stimulating mTOR, we're snacking all the time, we're exposed to EMFs, we've got iron fortified foods, we're drinking protein shakes, we're consuming dairy. So all of those things are stimulating mTOR when we have a cancer diagnosis, we don't want to be pushing mTOR the growth pathway.
So we look at variants here, if you don't have variants, then you're not hyperstimulating for growth. If you do have variants, you could be stimulating for growth and we want to monitor that. And so we reduce all of those things that I just mentioned, we don't take iron and supplements, we don't eat iron fortified foods, we are monitoring our protein intake, you know, we are limiting dairy, we're avoiding EMF and limiting EMF.
Exposure using things to help block EMFs, you know, we're avoiding MSG and glutamate, so all of those things. And we want to promote atophagy, these things cannot be happening at the same time, so we can't be dominant in mTOR and atophagy, it's one or the other.
So atophagy kicks in when mTOR is quiet, and so when we're minimizing mTOR, you know, time restricted eating or fasting minimizes mTOR and kicks in atophagy. And that's what we want.
We want to promote atophagy, because like I said, everything that we're exposed to in our choices, availability of food and snacking all the time, you know, don't allow us to really get into this phase of atophagy with our body. So time restricted eating, one of the best ways to help promote atophagy.
Obviously, we don't really encourage time restricted eating, if you're already underweight or, you know, weight loss is unchecked. So we just need to monitor and really time restricted eating is not the goal is not to lose weight.
It is just to minimize the time when you're getting all of your calories in so a narrower window of time so that you are in a fasting state for a longer period of time so your body can kick into atophagy and do that cellular repair and clean up.
But talk to us first before just implementing time restricted eating, if you are underweight or are losing weight or, you know, are struggling with that. But all of these genes are in the atophagy section. So if you have variance here where we'll probably implement some things to help with atophagy.
Atophagy, curcumin helps with atophagy, support atophagy, reservoir atrol helps support atophagy. So those might be some interventions we might begin to implement.
DNA repair so kind of along the same lines of atophagy cellular repair and clean up so these genes are also involved so everything we just talked about would be beneficial if you have variance in these categories here.
Alright, the urea cycle the urea cycle is helping us to get rid of excess ammonia to access ammonia is something that we do not want and these genes here are helping us get rid of that. So we want to make sure you're staying hydrated flush the kidneys to help get rid of excess ammonia.
We have something called ammonia scavenger if this is an issue.
So looking at all of these genes here gives us an indication as to whether or not we need to support the urea cycle. Let's see here.
Alright, looking at this, this gene is an interesting one, CAC NA1C. So this is a gene that gives us clues as to people who might be extra sensitive to EMFs.
So we kind of touched on EMFs a little bit we're constantly being exposed to the wireless signal we've got our cell phones on our person on our body most of the time we're in our office working on the computer.
So we're constantly being exposed to EMFs and there are people who are sensitive to EMFs and you would have some variance here. I mean, even if you didn't have variance you might be sensitive to EMFs, but certainly from a genetic perspective variance here indicate a sensitivity to this so you would want to implement if you are not already some
ways to help protect the body from EMF exposure. So turning Wi-Fi off at night, filling your home with plants, plants help absorb some of that radiation. So putting plants concentrated amount of plants in the room where your Wi-Fi router is can help absorb that radiation getting outside and grounding putting your feet on the earth helps your body get rid of those ions that are destructive most positive ions
to help you become more negative or grounding in your charge.
So that's helpful certainly an important one for health and healing overall. There are products that you can purchase as well.
We have he drawn products available on our web store. So those are little stickers or things that it can attach to your devices.
Put on the back of your cell phone, put on your computer so it it helps to negate some of the exposure to the body right and then we look at some of these minerals here. So looking at copper looking at iron looking at magnesium.
So iron and copper are two minerals that we definitely do not want our patients to be supplementing with if you have a cancer diagnosis because they can encourage blood vessel formation can encourage cancer growth iron can fuel cancer.
So we take patients off of supplements when they come to us with their supplements. If they have iron or copper in them, we take them off of those.
So we don't necessarily give you any or do anything of copper iron.
So if you have any ions have variations in them, iron is a tricky one because certainly iron is necessary, a necessary component for cellular health for oxygenation of tissue if we are anemic which is, you know, happens a lot with cancer patients.
So we, how do we support that because we, we don't necessarily want to give iron, but if you're at a point where you are really anemic or your level is really low and you might need a transfusion or something we have some initial steps where we do provide some iron and supplemental form, but we follow it up with a cancer fighter, whether it's Artemis and in or Burberry, so we follow it up with that.
If your cells are up taking some of that iron in the supplement, they're also up taking that cancer fighter as well.
So the goal is to kind of, you know, attack the cancer cells with that cancer fighter and allow some of the healthy cells to get the iron that is necessary.
There are a lot of strategies if iron is an issue, we have some protocols because anemia is something that a lot of patients struggle with might be related to some genetic variance here, some genetic variance will increase iron absorption and you might be at risk for something called hemochromatosis, which can be inflammatory.
So too much iron is not good, too little iron is not good, so once again it's about creating that balance.
So if you have hemochromatosis or high ferritin or something like that, ferritin is an inflammatory marker, we want to really work to reduce inflammation could be cancer related, so we want to really work to, you know, just fight the cancer as much as we can work to reduce inflammation.
And, you know, come come talk to us and we can talk specifically about an iron protocol if anemia is the case.
So trying to strike that balance there with iron a difficult one magnesium is just all around good unless you have diarrhea, then magnesium would maybe not be so good.
But magnesium is one that we don't need to be concerned about as far as supplementing with it so magnesium is a cofactor in many many metabolic processes that we are talking about many of these genetic pathways require magnesium so magnesium is is great on there's different forms of magnesium that are better for certain things.
So, but magnesium is is good again, unless you have diarrhea too much magnesium can can stimulate some diarrhea so if that is a problem for you and you're taking magnesium maybe you want to back off on that a little bit.
All right, we're winding down here we have some repeat genes here this is a category that is just specific taking a closer look into glutamate production so again glutamates are excitatory GABA is calming so these are gene genes and genetic pathways that are related to this balance we talked about that.
And we address issues there.
And then the last few ones here again related to glutamate so some of these PSAT1 ASNS so these are tumor suppressor genes that we also look at that don't not all of the tumor suppressor genes come up in this report.
So let's just talk about that for a second because within your genetic summary that we've created you also have a list at the very end of the last couple pages are related to tumor suppressor genes so not all of those that are listed there come up in this report some of them do.
But we are looking up each one of these that are listed on those pages in your database of all of your genes that were analyzed and so we're looking is up individually.
And again we have highlighted the ones that are at risk for you so pay attention to the highlighted ones and then there's lists of possible interventions based on those and so again we're not asking you to implement all of those interventions.
But we've listed on your genetic action steps the interventions that we want you to apply so maybe you're already eating a specific diet and that is supporting a specific tumor suppressor gene so anything that we want to add to give extra support or to make sure we have enough support is on that list of genetic action steps so look at those tumor suppressor genes.
And the ones that are highlighted are the most important for you as well.
So that brings us through the report lots of information lots of data and hopefully this was helpful certainly you can dig a lot deeper into genetics if you wish.
Connor's has tons of videos and blog posts about genetics he has a video book called cancer genes that you can take a look at that is available for you don't even have to download it but you go to the book part of our website and click on cancer genes that will bring up all of the videos that are associated with that video book.
You can look at that if you'd like to dig deeper but certainly we hope this was helpful and if you do have other questions you know you can chat them in or you know you can ask on one of the weekly zoom calls if you have a genetic question but hopefully this video is helpful and just kind of interpreting all of this information gives you some insights as to what we're looking at and.
And then hopefully with your genetic summary and your genetic action steps you are more clear on some of the things that we are asking you to implement that are addressing your genetic variance so.
I hope this helps have a good day everyone thanks for listening bye bye.